nous n'avons pas perdu le contrôle nous
sommes dans une situation qui est
préoccupante
la rumeur courait depuis plusieurs jours
hier soir emmanuel macron en un fait une
réalité
après avoir expérimenté deux mois de
confinement en empruntant une partie du
territoire français s'apprête à vivre
sous couvre feu une mesure d'exception
censée lutter contre la propagation du
coronavirus cet objectif de manière très
concrète c'est freiner le virus c'est
faire que ces vingt mille nouveaux cas
par jour
on va devoir les ramener à 3 5000 cas
par jour parce que là on peut maîtriser
c'est que ces 200 entrées en réanimation
doit aussi fortement les réduire pour au
fond revenir à un niveau de nombre de
cas qu vide en réanimation qui est de
l'ordre de 10 à 15% d'honorer au maximum
parce que là c'est soutenable
conséquence un couvre-feu entrera bien
en vigueur dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi en ile de france et dans huit
métropoles dont celle de l'île d'aix
marseille ou encore la métropole
lyonnaise
des restrictions de circulation entre
21h et 6h du matin qui concerneront près
de 20 millions de français
ce couvre-feu sera instauré pour un mois
une durée que le président compte déjà
étendre à 6 semaines soit jusqu'au mois
de décembre minimum sous condition
d'approbation par le parlement comme
lors du confinement des dérogations
seront possibles pour ceux travaillant
en horaires décalés et des sanctions
seront appliquées pour les contrevenants
135 euros d'amande et 1500 euros en cas
de récidive pas non plus de limitations
dans les transports publics
les français pourront bien partir en
vacances à la toussaint comme vous
l'avez dit choix de ne pas infantiliser
mais de responsabiliser et donc ça veut
dire qu'on n'empêche pas les gens de
passer d'une région à l'autre
autre est d'ailleurs concrètement de
partir en vacances mais on va leur
demander de respecter des règles de
citoyenneté
pendant les semaines et les mois qui
viennent au-delà de ces mesures le
président de la république en a appelé à
la responsabilité de chacun éviter les
rassemblements au delà de six personnes
porter le masque au maximum et favoriser
le télétravail deux à trois jours par
semaine si possible autre annonce la
refonte de l'application stop qu'ovide
qui n'a pas fait ses preuves
quatre mois après son lancement en juin
dernier
le président a par ailleurs annoncé la
reconduction des aides pour soutenir le
secteur pénalisé par le couvre-feu les
bars les hôtels les restaurants déjà
très touché par les mesures de
confinement qui bénéficieront de
dispositifs de soutien supplémentaires
nous allons améliorer la réponse
économique avec tous ces professionnels
je le dis je pense en particulier à nos
restaurateurs nous aurons des
dispositifs de soutien supplémentaire
c'est à dire qu'on va améliorer
l'accompagnement économique de tous ces
secteurs dans les métropoles où le
couvre-feu est installé parce que pour
certains il faudra faire plus que ce
qu'on a fait afin de lutter contre
l'augmentation de la pauvreté une aide
exceptionnelle de 150 euros sera
également versée aux bénéficiaires du
rsa et de l'aide personnalisée au
logement